hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to little nightmares now
this game is something that I've been
following for a while now and if you
don't know anything about the game
you're kind of in the same boat that I
am but what I do know is that you seem
to be a tiny little fellow that is in a
world that he does not belong or she I'm
not entirely sure and in this world
everything seems to be much bigger than
you are someone in a top hat maybe
myself I hello okay
so that's how we're gonna start this
game so yeah this is who you are
either way you almost seem like a child
lost in a world that doesn't want you in
here and that can be terrifying by
itself oh okay but one thing that I've
seen and and again I haven't explored
too much about the game but one thing
that I've seen is that the environments
are just big and expansive not just in
like oh it's open-world but literally to
you they are big and expansive because
this world wasn't it oh okay go away
please
but this world was not meant for you
this world was not meant for me whoever
this person is they're not supposed to
be here or maybe they are maybe this
place has been invaded but you'll see
soon enough what I'm talking about no no
what I'm supposed to do here
Oh press F to use the lighter oh well
that's handy I wouldn't have known about
that until you told me oh so it was oops
no it was oh there we go okay all right
good so now we just need to go in the
hatch we'll carry on in this nightmarish
world how do i crawl oh it's just like
that and every other game you press the
ctrl button and you crawl all right
Hidy Hidy Hidy ho i don't know where to
go hello
okay yes spastically jump up and down as
best you can over there
okay hello why can't I move forward here
does not want me to move forward oh no
oh no oh no oh I already broke the game
hello hi my name is barbed wire I break
every game that I find Oh No oh where am
I
oh I'm dead well Frick me then I warp
through the world and then fell down
because I am too dumb okay let's carry
back to where I was admittedly that was
probably a rare bug but if it keeps
happening I'm gonna hold it against it
can't help it well there we go oh now
we're going smooth okay let's just
pretend like that never happened unless
it happens again and I'm gonna make fun
of it relentlessly over and over and
over again where am i because in a way
it reminds me of inside and it reminds
me of
[Music]
limbo limbo is what it was called
God man my brain you could hear the cogs
slowly getting the rust and cobwebs out
of them
trying to remember that name but yeah
it's kind of like this side-scrolling
adventure but this one is a bit more
freeform than that one was or maybe it's
exactly the same amount of freeform it's
hard to tell these days I don't know if
I'm doing anything but okay all right so
is that another lamp that I can light Oh
No ooh
is that Japanese doll oh just pick it up
then okay all right then I don't know
why I'm taking this but I'm gonna take
it with me on an adventure
come along Geri the Japanese doll doing
this yeah Oh No why is that hanging in
the sky Oh No
what was that okay a little bit of
parallax scrolling there going on there
can I hide under here because something
might come in here No all righty then
so I'm gonna try to get on this thing
but I guess I can't carry that anymore
I'll just go on my way boeing-boeing a
boy between there we go okay oh hi at
least it was a cushy landing oh I just
noticed the legs and what's with the
chairs wait if you look in the
background they're all warped out of
place what is that what is any of this
oh my god
are you kidding me can I get this note
oh man I guess maybe my characters just
not interested in that
why is there an eyeball on the door oh
no I'm gonna need to take that chair
excuse me don't mind me it's just gonna
grab this chair I need it's my friend
you call it cherry all righty then oh
boy this is already taken
dark turn I guess that's why it's called
little nightmares got it okay pop up
there Oh
boink yay I solve the puzzle and I win
it or I'm I don't wanna go in yeah
yes black goop exactly what I wanted in
my adventures and what the hell is with
the machinery in the background where
are their hands on that door trailing
from the black goop that does not bode
well for me that spells death
all right fine then Frick you I moan in
here yeah
oh hi so there's nothing but a pair of
shoes in the refrigerator that is trail
of blood led to and I don't know why
that doll was there I wasn't able to
take the doll with me I wouldn't have
been able to climb up with it I don't
think anyway alright who's here oh I
don't know if I want to crawl through
here but here I go apparently alrighty
then oh right like this I'm guessing
this is like a check okay hi how you
doing how are you doing okay I'm just
gonna it's gonna you're just gonna
completely ignore me then so this must
be a checkpoint I'm some sort of save
system so when I hit bad definitely
saves I see how you work so if I go back
there might be some other way to go and
something leading to some sort of
monstrosity but like I don't know what
that guy was was that one of me
was that what that was like some sort of
representation of of myself maybe I
can't climb up here can I so there's got
to be something to do with this maybe I
can oh well don't do that just yet but
climb up that and try to get oh oh
that's why that fridge was made all
we're don't like oh god oh good oh good
I mean not good I still don't know what
the hell's going on here but still
getting used to the controls but at
least oh no you don't hello
oh I don't want to do this but let it
happen is to see I just closed oh why
the poor little guy
oh here I am not dead it's waking up in
an alternate reality to the bouzouki
okay you're not gonna get me I'm gonna
bushu the heck out of here
then I'll carry on I'll don't you
freakin dare no no no no no no no good
think I don't have a stamina bar in like
the last one all right Joe Borowski okay
carry me away carry me away oh my god
it's so cool I'm going through these so
fast I think I might be missing
something but oh okay
I mean I just wanted to get away from
those things those things so quickly
okay can I do this ooh not quite there
so how about this one oh no not quite
there either whoa oh oh I should have
known or maybe I shouldn't have known I
don't know if I could have known that oh
boy hey hey buddy how you doing why do
you squiggle ah this is not good Oh No
all right no oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh no no no no no don't thank you no
thank you no thank you oh god oh god oh
god what the [ __ ] was that about
oh no they all swarmed me that's not
comfortable at all oMG I am supposed to
come down here well I see how this is
okay so you're there you're there you're
there there's a snare Oh escape route oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay okay okay okay no no okay no no no
no oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
pull this off I guess pull this off do I
do some oh my god those little bastards
oh okay well I did that I guess good I'm
lighting the fires freaky dick I don't
know if I've had a chance to miss
anything yet I haven't had a chance to
look anywhere for anything I can stop it
and everything is terrifying when you're
tiny like this and what's with the black
ink creatures like what is that and what
are those things with the cones on their
head ah I have no idea I have no idea at
all but it's charming and terrifying at
the same time whoo wait was there
something back there they might have
been another way to go over here but I'm
not harmed sure nope that is a way to
instant deaths Alissa's keep moving here
so maybe those things are related like
the things that put the handprints might
be those little guys and they might all
be from this black ooze and this black
ooze is definitely something I just
don't know what to find out it should be
running but here I go bold into the
darkness point come on now oh yay no
more darkness oh yay okay I can make
this jump get it Oh Oh long jump baby
boo boo boo boo boo I made it
what is it all for like what's the
purpose of it why did I choose to leave
the safety of my briefcase to go hi
they're so fast they're too fast to be
comfortable for me so that is don't want
to deal with that anymore oh okay then
are you just rejecting mirrors this I
can't open it it's not a good leveraging
on that okay so he went down there but
there is something up here okay
somewhere up here somewhere to go huh
maybe I can squeeze yeah what was the
point of this nothing Oh what have whoa
it fell down ow my knees oh I have a
paper airplane will be the point of this
is there a special reason for this is
this just an artistic object that's in
the world that I'm supposed to just grab
and maybe half does this have any whoa
nice sweet throw bruh congratulations
you saw an expert at that oh alright not
very good
hello that's good but again I can't
exactly do anything with it here so I
guess I'll just toss it off into the
distance
oh all right goodbye oh boy
okay I'm gonna climb up here where
apparently someone escaped from what
looks like jail why would I be breaking
in to jail like what would be the
benefit of that to me why is the camera
doing it like that why is the camera all
shaky I mean I love the dynamicism of
the camera but it's not good for my
psyche don't go back down come on no I
didn't do that
why would you do that fine then I'm
still gonna go for it and again I don't
know what that is oh well I see more of
you now God what the Frick are you all
right come on get up there come on go go
go go baby go now this time when you get
up there please do not fall down like an
idiot I think this is supposed to be
played with a gamepad not uh not what
I've been doing here there we go okay
cuz it's just the tiniest bit janky on a
keyboard well that's okay because I'm
gonna get it just fine can you light
that please thank you okay so that must
have saved that and for some reason
these eyes seem to be a theme here so if
there's something to do about the eye
there's that toilet paper that giant
toilet paper bigger than my head oh I'm
in a bathroom I just noticed that grow
[Laughter]
fricken grows why do I have this oh
that's electrified Oh Han so maybe if I
pick this up and throw it at the wall
it's gonna light on fire oh that's
definitely electrified and you can't
fool me that is a hundred percent Oh
look around by using this what Oh Oh
oh no no let go of that I didn't even do
that okay close this door come on come
on closer closer closer close it good
okay so what I got to do is I got to
take this over here and then I gotta
jump on this
I gotta slam this the poop stool grab
that and bam oh go quick or else you're
gonna die okay well we're here now and
there's more eyeballs and as my hand
prints why is that from a baby one of
the giant things are presented for me
being subjected to these horrors okay we
did it I guess we didn't need to do any
of that if we were just gonna go over
there where am I now like going back in
the [ __ ] and room why would I want to go
back in the [ __ ] room
oh is that just another way that I could
have gone and I wasn't supposed to go
that way immediately because I'm too
smart and I wanted to go better way is
that what I did poop okay
whoa nope I can't jump there there we go
you buddy
nope too bad for me okay merry-go-round
why
what would be the benefit of this why is
this here am I about to be hit by that
train and die good oh wow oh I detached
it oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
alright so there's gotta be an
electrical system over here that means
that I got to find it and shut it off
somehow so we're aware is the electrics
oh no I'm so sorry I didn't mean to do
that [ __ ] your [ __ ] oh I think I see it
ah I think I see it I think I see it
run jump grab I got this like a mouse
okay so what is that okay sorry I know
that's bad luck in any game ever oh wait
I know what I need to do oh it's the
same it's the same electrical box for
both of them ah so I've gotta somehow
get through both of these bad boys in
the same amount of time I see but now
that I know that I'm able to better
handle it and then I can just sprint
through here really quickly as fast as I
can sprint through there get through
there don't well I don't know what the
hell you just did I think you bounced
your skull off that bad boy well forget
about that you've got to go
ma-mutt oh that's creepy in the darkness
creepy creepy crawly creepy girly goo oh
yes just barely dude just barely man
this security system needs some work if
a little like infantile child is able to
do it and also why do they have so many
blocks like playing blocks meant for
little children not meant for big strong
whatever the hell you are what are you
Oh No Oh were their babies
gonna do to me oh my oh my god oh my god
oh that's horrible
oh that's horrible oh yeah wake up it's
time to get moving and not die again
there's poor kid at least I'm assuming a
kid but this poor kid and what the hell
is this set up for and the eyes come
back as a theme except this time it's
literally killing us
wait just looking at us oh no no oh okay
are you okay there you caught a few you
caught a few flashes there oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
okay so there's got to be a way out okay
I see I see I'm almost there I'm saying
Oh
[Music]
too close Oh too close almost got melted
like you know Terminator 2 James okay by
the way this is much better playing this
uh with a controller than it was oh come
on that looks like you can climb it oh
you can't climb it okay there we go
having a bob oh but do we do don't mind
me I'm gonna die okay
so there's something else here there was
something over there there was something
down there in that cage and I couldn't
go down there so let's do that I don't
want to miss out on the obvious stuff if
it's staring at me right in the face
hello where are you going you little
scamp come back here hello ah you think
you blended in you did not I'll light
this for you there you go
what are you it oh it's looking at the
painting all this so weird
but why is the painting of it or is it
looking at it because it kind of reminds
it of itself whatever it is I mean maybe
that's a human
maybe that's what those dead babies out
there were these like I don't know what
it is but something bizarre is happening
in this world even know what I don't
even know how to make sense of it what
is pick what is this place come on you
can make that jump
there you go what is the point of
lighting the torches then if it's just
to provide light for those little guys
then maybe that is a reward unto itself
but getting to think of them maybe not
oh good landing in a nice soft pile of
ashes ah so comforting to know that so
many died cushioned my fall let's carry
on there's another way to go over here
so let us almost fell down right into
the direction of the eye and I can only
assume that these are all like prison
cells right whoa oh there's another one
of the dolls what do I do with you I
don't know what to do with it what I
would do with it you go under the bed
maybe understand here you know relax
under there you stay under there that's
where that's where you probably want to
be oh geez okay I can't even jump when
I'm on that thing so let me try to get
on the bed let me try to jump for fun
Hey
it's so fun this is watching me being a
bad kid jeez I'm not getting any higher
all right tuck and roll and let's get
out of here I don't know what the point
of that was unless there's something
secret starting in the wings no just a
bunch of handprints and for some reason
an open door but it seems like this was
made by someone my size as well
and again I just don't know how it all
correlates but that's what I meant when
I said I don't know a lot about this
game when I go into these things I want
to know as little as possible because
like uncovering the mystery of it is
half the fun and I'm gonna drop for this
yes I don't know what the point of this
was I can't even grab on to this can I
know I might be able to swing it if I
was like really persistent but I'm
really not
so I'm just gonna keep going because I
don't know what the end goal of that
would be and I'm just gonna probably
waste my time if I try hi okay oh my god
oh my god what are you oh oh no no don't
you reach your long arm under here you
oh no all the children see leaping okay
bye-bye
okay bye e
oh they're sleeping but why did it so
maybe it wouldn't have killed me I feel
like it may have put me to bed or
something I can't even climb up here can
I talk to you it seems like it might be
important to talk to you but it's not
letting me climb up there okay I'll
carry on then let's carry on oh my own
yeope t no it's won't let me up there
they're all sleeping but man
I mean if those are infants that are the
size of me again that doesn't bode well
with all these giants are around here
yeah I thought these playing blocks
might have been a little big but why are
all the kids dipping their hands in
black ink and painting well maybe the
idea of not going up there and talking
to them is because I don't want to talk
to them
that'd be a bad thing to do at this
juncture in my life okay I see what I
need to do I can climb up here okay
dooby doo doo boop man the camera is
really cool in the way it's just dynamic
like that I mean there's probably gonna
be a headache when I have the bad angles
and whatnot but for now you know it's
hard to program a good camera so they
did pretty good
I mean limbo of course in limbo and and
the other one inside both do a very good
job at it I hope to not draw too many
comparisons between those games at this
one but it is dark as blazes hello oh hi
how's it going okay oh that is a big-ass
trap although maybe on the contrary
maybe I've been thinking about this all
wrong maybe they're not giant maybe
they're normal sizes
I'm just abnormally tiny along with
those what hi why are you starving
please don't tell me you need to eat
that rat please don't tell me the point
of that was to eat the rat and make me
feel good about it please tell me that
wasn't the point oh no it was the point
wasn't it Oh No
was it okay maybe it wasn't because that
rat seems to be out of here but oh good
at least my kid needs some food so I'm
gonna try to provide be the best pop I
can know if I can't but I'll try oh no
wait that's not normal hunger is it
that's something that's something
different is that just hunger maybe it
is oh hi hello
apparently I'm extremely hungry or
extremely constipated please help
Obi Obi thank you I don't know what this
mystery meat is but I'm very grateful oh
oh
yay thank you thank you I think I think
this is good for me
I'm not sure though God you were I guess
we're about the same size actually now
that I think about it you're not that
much bigger than me thank you how do I
not thank you thank you very much I
really appreciate it you light the ways
I thank thee oh boy I can almost see
your face yeah you seem normal except
your skin is like ashen gray that's
weird
why okay bye thanks for the food I guess
you're gonna huddle in ol ball and
regret giving me that food I guess okay
carrying on carrying on why is there a
noose in this room why is there a news
in this room why does there need to be a
noose in this room I don't know
and why did the first room like the
first actual quiet these are frickin big
showers for a freaking big clean am i
right I need a big size well I'm just
gonna Corrine off into the abyss and
then never ever ever continue this
adventure again no come on you can do
better than man I know you can come on
get out there and show the world what
you got fill the world your stuff and
everything that comes along with it it
is very easy to just end up drifting off
the edge there because of the way the
cameras changes so much it the the
perspective of where you're going is all
dependent on the camera angle which is
kind of funky or maybe it's not maybe
it's the other way around but it just
seems that way to me
whoa I'm gonna do sweet walljump wink
hell yeah did that nailed it I'm so good
at this
all right so why did I have so many
cages by the way I've never even
contemplated the idea that there these
are all in fact cages and lockers and
then why would any civilization need
this many cages like why what's the
point of this loopy all right come on
swing swan we're gonna swing swung here
what are we gonna do where am I gonna go
and also why is this here maybe I can do
this am I actually manipulating it or am
I not
nope that was a mistake okay well I
don't know where I was just then was
that where I was supposed to be or where
is it was there something else no idea
okay but I think that wasn't right so I
gotta use physics or something to go
okay so I gotta use unless I climb up
this oh that makes a lot more sense in
trying to swing swung it over to the
other side
Savion such a goof and maybe go the
right direction and I'll be fine yeah
mmm what's at the top of the chain yeah
I thought about jumping but maybe there
was something up here probably it's a
pulley mechanism and I need not have
gone this high just kind of a factor
that I could and I did it anyway because
I'm curious oh my gosh darn Gary's
little rain coat wearing kid like in all
honesty maybe I am exactly the same as
the others but it just doesn't seem like
that might be true it's just hard to
tell when my eyes are covered like this
and this this this is a normal-sized
ladder so there's some weird
juxtaposition of what is normal size
than one is not normal sized given the
only normal sized thing I've seen are
the other children like me and then
again maybe they are not normal size and
I'm just extremely malnourished because
everything wants to kill me and you know
maybe maybe there's other factors too I
don't know yeah I got that up here why
did I need to do that chuckles okay I'm
gonna go for it no you come back here
you come back here you come back here
now you come back here now I'm gonna get
on you eventually and then you're gonna
let me ride you right up until the end
you you make sense with that one so if I
climb on this thing I should be able to
get up there right yes I am because I am
a deductive logical creature hello why
is there lightning in the distance ooh
filing cabinets but why though can't
open this I find them
yeah there we go climb up on that one
maybe ooh yes and then hope they okay
that's that that's less than good I
think that seems unger des someone might
notice that when someone might notice
that one oh hey can i push this in here
please tell me this isn't the one where
that guy's hanging oh hi
it's a noose though it is indeed a noose
oh hi are you in a cage why is that one
in a cage there's got to be a reason
that they're changing them up right it's
got to be a reason oh okay it was a
reason I did that damn it all right oh
no why why why why why why why why why
why why why are they here now why are
they here now and why is everything dark
oh that's right that didn't just shut
off the power there that shut off the
power everywhere I forgot I was going
here I totally forgot that that was my
point
Oh Ricky okay all right then Wow okay
minor boat
I think I'm on a boat I'm on him I'm on
a boat this is super weird why am I on a
boat and this boat is is bizarrely
intricate which is just super weird wow
that was close
okay fine we're fine hey I there's no
problem here there's there's no problem
at all should be whoopty whoopty whoopty
I'm out of here
why is the eye there what oh come on
what do you make that so easy to do huh
why do you make that so easy to do oh
come on I'm behind the eye again you son
of a bails get I'm gonna try this one go
back this way
cuz this seems like a marginally better
way than it was before yeah this is easy
why wouldn't everybody just go behind
because it seems to me like I seems to
me like there was a very clear oh no
come on
what do you climb on that thing don't do
that don't be so eager you're gonna die
hey let's go let's not careen off the
edge huh how about that
whoa you almost did it again Mikey okay
we're fine we're fine I don't know why
this is happening but we're fine
oh I see I needed to get up here or else
I would have died okay
like a goof oh where are you locking me
and now hi okay I'm not gonna stand in
the way there or maybe I will I thought
that was gonna be another situation with
the I okay but we're out of there and I
got an achievement for the prison I
don't know what that means but we made
it to another area and thankfully this
eye is offline so I'm gonna end this
episode here thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you figure
that's down in the comments below I have
so many questions going through my mind
as to what this is all about and who
this kid is and why I was in the prison
in the first place did I escape from
there maybe I was originally inhabiting
that and I was starving because I tried
to escape and therefore there's this
other world of other larger creatures
that captured us and changed us I have
no idea something about the inky
blackness is just corrupting everything
but either way thank you so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]